Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2 marks the first
big-screen incarnation of Marvel Comics character
Mantis, played by Korean-French actress Pom
Klementieff.
While she was relatively unknown before landing
her big break in the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
there's still a chance you might have seen
Klementieff before.
Here's why Mantis may have looked familiar.
Early years
Klementieff got her start on camera fresh
out of drama school in independent French
films.
Her first starring gig was in 2009's Wolf
as a Siberian reindeer herder.
She followed it up with smaller roles over
the next few years in a wide variety of releases,
including a string of parts in 2011, with
appearances in action thriller Sleepless Night
and crime comedy Borderline, just to name
a few …
Klementieff also appeared in 2012 gross out
comedy Porn in the Hood, the most profitable
French film of the year.
Oldboy
Before landing the role of Mantis, Klementieff's
highest-profile performance by far was as
a bodyguard in Spike Lee's 2013 remake of
the 2003 South Korean thriller Oldboy, a very
physical role that required intense training.
A fan of the original Oldboy, she wanted to
make sure the fight scenes were up to snuff,
and endured a strict regimen to prepare …
"I spent two months in New Orleans training
martial arts for three hours a day for two
months, yeah."
"As I said, I lost a toenail, but after the
end of the movie, because I'm a professional."
Hacker's Game
After breaking out with Oldboy, Klementieff
landed a starring role in the widely panned
2015 mid-budget romantic thriller Hacker's
Game, a high-stakes relationship drama between
two high-level hackers.
Klementieff plays Loise, officially a cyber-detective
who falls for an Edward Snowden-like figure
"How did my files end up on your computer?"
"Who are you spying on, her or me?"
"I'm just trying to save that nice ass of
yours."
The first film of Klementieff's to give the
actress top billing was also her first major
misstep, with the Los Angeles Times in particular
throwing some serious shade her way, saying
she displayed "the acting range of a petulant
child."
"What are we doing?"
Sundance star
If you were fortunate enough to attend the
2017 Sundance Film Festival, you may have
seen Klementieff on a few panels and in two
supporting roles in films making their debut:
the social media dating drama Newness … and
the social media stalking comedy Ingrid Goes
West, starring Aubrey Plaza, which hits theaters
in August.
A look ahead
We already know Klementieff will be back in
2018's Avengers: Infinity War, which brings
the Guardians face to face with the Avengers,
and James Gunn hinted in a Facebook post that
she would be back for confirmed sequel Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 3, as well, saying his
love for Mantis and her fellow Guardians "goes
deeper than you guys can possibly imagine."
You can just feel the love ...
"You feel...
sexual love."
"No, no I don't."
"For her!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!